c'est au coeur du stand de paris saclay
que saint quentin en yvelines présente
ses atouts
accueil de la ryder cup en 2018 mais
aussi sa bonne forme en matière de
transactions immobilières pour l'année
en cours
4 6 millions de mètres carrés
d'immobilier d'entreprise un taux de
vacance à 6 7% ou encore 250 mille
mètres carrés de projets immobiliers en
développement un secteur dynamique
destinée à convaincre les futurs
investisseurs il est indispensable qu'on
soit là qu'on rencontre tout le monde
qu'on voit les nouveautés les
innovations une nouvelle proposition
comment on peut être plus rentable être
plus plus rapide être être plus simple
parce que c'est important d'être simple
aujourd'hui telle simplification pour
qu'on comprenne là on va cette année
saint quentin en yvelines mais aussi
versailles grand parc et paris saclay
ont proposé une conférence commune sur
les grands événements internationaux
faire stand commun c'est aussi la
volonté du département des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine
objectif mettre en avant l'attractivité
de ces deux territoires de l'ouest
francilien nous faisons l'aménagement de
notre territoire
la promotion de l'attractivité ensemble
donc avec une force de frappe beaucoup
plus importante avec une efficacité sur
le terrain ou bien meilleur il faut être
là où sont les investisseurs puisque
c'est eux que nous chassons pour porter
du développement dans l'echo dans nos
communes dans nos territoires
parce que ce développement crée de la
richesse fiscale et de l'emploi des
enjeux économiques importants donc pour
saint quentin en yvelines et notre
département jusqu'à la fermeture de ses
portes vendredi le salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise devrait accueillir plus de
28 mille visiteurs